inflation figures for November have just
been published you might want to look
away now the inflation currently running
at 10.7 let's bring in our business
correspondent Paul Kelso joining us from
birmingham's wholesale Market Paul good
morning to you um I mean I watching to
put it mildly
it is an eye watering figure almost as
eye-watering as the temperatures here
this morning the Traders here earning
their money this week in these
temperatures but amazingly that figure
10.7 up near 40 years highs is actually
a little glimmer of good news it's off
the peak we saw what may be the peak of
inflation in the last monthly figures of
11.1 certainly everybody here and around
the country will be hoping this does
signify we've hit the top of the
inflationary curve 10.7 of course still
a huge amount to bear on the cost of
living but trade is here saying already
they are seats starting to see a little
bit of an impact in a small reduction in
prices they put that down to fuel prices
easing slightly and that could be
passing on through to customers this
place serves the restaurants and shops
of Birmingham and the West Midlands so
the produce bought here the price paid
in this market feeds right the way
through the local economy into the
prices people paying are paying in the
shots of course this number we watched
very keenly also in Westminster this is
incredibly High inflation the backdrop
fueling the industrial action we've seen
over the last few months intensifying
over this Christmas period yesterday we
sort of heard that wages were Rising uh
only four percent in real terms way
below the real cost of inflation at 10.7
that number isn't going to change
dramatically and this will simply
perhaps going to entrench the views of
those on the receiving end of these
Rising costs the workers who are
demonstrating and taking industrial
action for higher pay against the
government that seems at the moment more
intent on offsetting the impact of
strikes than working to end them but
here Traders just sensing a little bit
of good news in these prices rising
still very high but not as high as last
month I apologize as you say those
industrial disputes ongoing negotiations
such as they are at not yet completed
with inflation running you know ahead
away from 11 does it strengthen or
weaken the government's case that to
give you know huge sway to the public
sector significant pay rises above the
three four percent that some are talking
about right now that that would be
inflationary in and of itself does it
does this weaken or strengthen their
case
uh I'm yet to check what the reaction is
from the chance of the exchequer we will
get one uh very promptly this morning
but I imagine that will be precisely his
argument with inflation running so high
to fuel to to add High pay uh what they
would see is high pay settlements in the
public sector would further fuel that
Invasion would fuel what is known as a
wage price spiral that is as prices rise
wages Rises to keep up that entrenches
high prices there is a strong argument
though that's made on the public sector
side of this that there's no cost to the
economy of paying public sector workers
more they will spend that money in the
economy but there are no goods and
services that are getting more expensive
because you're paying nurses more or
paying teachers more in fact you may be
feeding some of that money back into the
tax system in due course and remember
wages are not as high as inflation a
classic wage price spiral is when wages
are at or exceeding inflation at the
moment they are well behind that rate of
inflation I'm sure the counter argument
from the unions will be that people
simply need enough pay to keep up with
prices and of course certainly in the
public sector we're seeing the compound
impact of a decade of austerity real
wages way below where they were they
haven't kept up within inflation but
that argument is at the heart of these
industrial disputes and I suspect we
will see in the coming days those
positions entrenching rather than being
eased by the fact that inflation may
just may have reached its peak